this soldier died for a country vladimir
putin doesn't think should exist
the russian president's decree
recognizing a part of eastern ukraine as
two new independent republics is
according to kiev's defense minister an
attack on its territorial dignity i hope
that
leaders of different countries
which promised us
that the sanctions will be started
after the invasion
i think that the paper
invasion
began
ukraine's president says he doesn't
believe russia will launch all-out war
against his country but he wants the
international community to react
decisively against what he calls a new
act of russian aggression
we believe that by taking this decision
the russian federation creates a legal
basis for further military aggression
against ukraine violating all bilateral
and multilateral agreements
that's not how russia's parliament sees
it
here vladimir putin's decision is
welcomed as the writing of an historical
wrong just like the annexation of crimea
no this is an historic day just like
seven years ago when crimea returned to
the fault and became part of the russian
federation today now and forever there
will be two new sovereign states on the
world political map the donetsk and
lugansk people's republics
putin met his counterpart from
azerbaijan on tuesday does the man who
once lamented the collapse of the soviet
union as the demise of historical russia
have further expansionist plans
we predicted speculation that russia
plans to restore its empire within its
imperial border this absolutely does not
correspond with reality
the kremlin says recognizing as
independent the two breakaway ukrainian
regions will help restore calm adding
that it remains open to diplomacy with
the u.s and other countries russia also
dismisses allegations that it sent its
forces into eastern ukraine the kremlin
says whether it does or not depends on
how the situation develops
bernard smith al jazeera moscow